now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
easy and affordable online therapy when
you want to be a better problem solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better
dot com help.com
trash tuesday
thank you to our sponsor rocket money
cancel unnecessary subscriptions with
rocket money today go to rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday seriously it could save
you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday what if i told you you can
grow thicker healthier hair and support
our show well then go to nutrifoal.com
and use code trash to save 15 off your
first month this is their best offer
anywhere and it's only available to us
customers for a limited time free
shipping on every order excuse me that's
15 off at n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com code trash
hi you guys welcome to literally the
best episode of trash tuesday that's
ever been recorded um guess what this
weekend i'm in austin texas please come
i can't wait to see you guys i can't
wait to be back on the road get tickets
at esther on ice.com and me and carlos
are looking for a place to stay let us
know i'm so excited to be back on the
road seeing you guys again i am going to
be
at the la jolla comedy store this
weekend i'm so excited it's one of my
favorite clubs in the world and i love
seeing you guys i'll be at the tempe
improv september 23rd through 24th i'm
doing one night at the caluso casino
please come to that you guys i want to
pack out it's going to be so fun that's
on the 30th we're going to be gambling
afterwards it's going to be insane so go
to annie letterman.com shows for that
and then every monday at 5 p.m pst 8 pm
pacific you can join me on don't bore me
my audio podcast on spotify live
okay esther and i have been so excited
about this day we're like we were your
fans just so you know so today we have
basically an only fan superstar
which isn't even what i how i
first knew who you were i've started
following you on tick tock
because i just liked your tick tocks but
turns out you're like in the top one no
the point one percent of only fans
creators stella berry welcome to the
show thank you
um hi to be here i notice on instagram
you go by anal princess i do it's the
best handle that was my original tic toc
well not my original was like my 15th
tiktok account but that was the one that
blew up on girls4u pages for the first
time
and so and that's because that's when i
started answering questions and like
not just marketing to men
and then that got deleted but it's so
it's my favorite username so i put it on
instagram well that's how i found you as
well i just thought you were somewhat i
thought you were like a tick-tock
educator yeah like i wish you are kind
of yeah yeah because you had that video
talking about
the colors of
vaginas yeah and i was like no one talks
about this so so smartly
yeah when and bringing up actual
genetics and haplogenes i was like oh
okay i do have really like random
knowledge because my mom is an ob gyn so
she gives me all this little like
information that i never would have
found out wait weren't you at some point
considering going into med school as
well yeah i did two years at ucla after
i graduated college i decided i want to
go to med school so i took two years of
pre-med at ucla and then took the mcat
was applying for med schools
was about to pay the 500 per school
application right and i was like i don't
want to do this anymore
and so i just started uh i'd already
been doing tick tock at that point and i
just went full force into porn okay
you know i have to ask you this as a top
only genius move yeah thank you the only
smart i'm proud of myself really proud
of myself like doing a genius movie okay
so you're a top point one percent only
fans creator and your mom is a
gynecologist so you know i have to ask
you what are your vagina tips for ugly
girls
no what about just like ugly girl vagina
health
smelly vagina
uh
i mean
shaver shaver wax oh i've waxed once and
i it was the worst thing ever hi annie
because there's welcome
[Music]
well put a bowl out for me yeah
um what i just want to make very clear
to everyone that the person with the
best education in this room is stella
this house in percent she went to nyu
and ucla yeah you're making us all look
like dumbed up it's it's one thing
here's the thing about you guys you're
smart enough to have done anything to be
a doctor to be a rocket scientist and
the fact that you chose porn is blowing
my mind but also like mad respect
yeah but i i think
that's why i picked porn is because
since i was a kid my parents have always
told me i can do anything i want and i
really always believed that and i always
acted on that too like when i after i
graduated college hadn't done any math
or science all of college i told my
college counselor that i wanted to go to
med school and i wanted to figure out
how to do it they're like honestly it's
kind of too late like you're way behind
other people blah blah and then i went
and spoke to my mom and she was like you
could literally go to med school at 40
if you were her mom's a doctor you can't
listen to people that tell you have to
follow a certain path like and she would
always be like that's why they're a
college counselor like you don't want to
end up a college counselor if you want
to end up a doctor do what you have to
do to become a doctor it's so like so
that's why i was like yeah i immediately
started at ucla and did all that and
then once i did the mcat and decided hey
this isn't what i want to do anymore my
parents also taught me like don't be the
dog that waits by the food bowl that's
not getting food when it can smell the
food in the other room you know what i
mean but it waits every day out of habit
because it's already it's already
invested so much time there it doesn't
want to move so they were always like
you got to be smarter than that and move
when you know you have to move and that
was what i did and i literally look back
and i'm so thankful because it's like
now i could go to med school any time i
wanted i have a question in the future
i'm sure though when like why porn and
what like were you like just did you
find yourself being like a hypersexual
good at it what like piqued your
interest and i thought that you were
already
super sexual like i lost my virginity at
13 and it was just pure curiosity and i
remember telling my mom about it because
we were always really open about sex and
we always have been and she was like
we're a very sexual family like we all
lost our virginities young all the women
in my family have like on my mom's side
have at least two kids by 18. it's just
kind of what our family does and so it
made a lot of sense to her like i never
felt judged for it and so i think i was
always really curious about sex that's
how i like to get to know people and so
then
porn
i always liked porn and i always thought
that would be so thrilling to do but i
never actually thought of it as a career
path for me because i was so you know as
much as i wanted to do what i wanted to
do i also wanted to make my parents
proud and
everything else and i didn't know much
about that industry either then i moved
to la which i think is how it happens
like most people and then you get
invited to sex parties from the girls
i've never been i've never been invited
to a sex party
that was girls in my organic chemistry
class
i took a whole year of organic chemistry
i was seven a.m to one the other day
like where was my invoice
with marlon jones at in in long beach i
was i never got invited to one i was in
oakheam for an entire [ __ ] year now i
got sex partying with that titty almost
hanging out i got it really lucky yeah
for real i don't know i don't even know
hardy so
first of all we should go together
we should go
okay first thing everyone always thinks
it's an orgy like everybody's always
like oh my god i don't know if i could
like have sex with all these people i'm
like doesn't know what happens the
majority of people there are watchers oh
my god he's like
yeah
and and they're different also people
think they're the same as sex clubs but
it's totally different so these member
sex parties in la like everyone knows
all these old people in la are total
perverts right
so
so the men we can talk about that more
can we all the all the hollywood
directors that are
extremely pervy so of course they're
gonna have sex parties but they
basically men pay a ton of money for
like five parties a year women pay like
20 bucks to get in but you have to be a
member of it
it's very easy for women
um
but do i get there they charge me the
old man rate
that just simply off the game they're
just like this will be like a hundred
grand a year
do you know how much the men pay
okay so one of them i know it's like a
200 grand a year membership fee
20 is nothing lila go find a husband
i think if they bring a woman to like
they get to bring women for free and
stuff whereas then if you're just a
woman going it's like twenty dollars
but then the other one that i know they
just recently changed their whole thing
and now you have to apply to be a member
and like say what your kinks are and
everything but i think they mostly let
most people in do they let
goes in
why did you look at me
it was really disrespectful
i think that they do because i have been
i i wouldn't say
i think honestly in the sex world like
everyone's hot because everyone's really
sexual but i would say some of the men
are not hot okay so yeah they let others
in okay good i love a good dog ugly
so then they have like five a year
maybe six a year and they always will
text you like the day of the location of
the house and it's always a different
house in the hills and you show up it's
different some of them are themed and
some of them you have to wear like gowns
and a mask and a men has to wear clothes
yeah
kind of yeah exactly and then other ones
are like you have to show up in 70s
outfits or
that one i want to go to yeah that was
the first one i went to and that one was
crazy it was literally like a 70s orgy
so you show up to the party everyone's
dressed like really well did you wear
roller skates and then i didn't this was
my very first one so i had no idea what
to expect and there was bands playing in
all the rooms and it felt so 70s and
like the house was super 70s it was like
truly boogie nights yeah and like you
couldn't show up in cheap outfits like
you had to look the part and then people
were just having a sex against the walls
they were having sex with the bands up
there and it was like and then and then
all the bedrooms two people are having
sex now these people already know each
other and you go with friends because i
don't want to just randomly go up to
someone so that's what people always
think they think oh you're just having
sex with strangers and that's what i
thought too but the more i've gone to
them i realized that so what they do in
the beginning is like
they break the ice with performances so
they have porn girls performing they
have couples performing that are like
members and stuff and then
usually like i don't think that many
people
if any have sex with people they just
met that night
people always bring dates you or they're
watchers so they're either watchers and
the best is to go with someone you want
to [ __ ] and you want to either [ __ ] you
dave
even todd would be just like in a corner
like what is wrong with her
yeah and so then you can like walk after
the performances people start moving
into the rooms about like 2 a.m or
something and you can
just start having sex on any of the beds
anywhere in the bathrooms anything and
then you can also like ask couples if
you can [ __ ] right next to them and are
you ever like stepping over people
humping to pee you're like oh 100
sometimes are they like pee over here or
like you want to go in the bathroom and
it's locked and you know people are
[ __ ] in there yeah like why is it
locked let me in can you be like kitty
cat exactly like please like man please
i'm sure you're okay you kind of give
like a hot hamster vibe i don't even
know how to explain it but i mean it
like from the bottom of my head i feel
it from from the inside of my [ __ ]
that's why donut likes her i know
wait so did you see the army hammer doc
have we seen that i have not seen that
i've heard some things though there's
yeah let's just say his dad's house was
sounded like quite a sex party well
doesn't he comes from money right yeah
it was just like yeah like generations
of wealth crazy sex old old money and
old men with money yeah like isn't it
like a 99.9 percent chance they are a
pervert i just think yeah
right it's like money yeah power and
money yeah what do you do did you guys
see the secrets of playboy doc yes i saw
someone yeah that
that's pervy yeah that is quite pervy
that is the classic and it was all old
rich men yeah it was like playing around
with their little power game i know
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp um i have a hard time
focusing
and that's something that
will really get in the way of your life
if you don't realize it and fix it
um it's something i discovered during
talk therapy
and
that's why today we're talking about
better help yeah what were you saying
it can be really tough to train your
brain to stay in problem-solving mode
when faced with a challenge in life but
when you learn how to find your own
solutions there really is no better
feeling you guys i've been having like
an up like a
reoccurrence of anxiety recently and
it's like talking to someone helps so
much with that because you can just spin
it over and over again and sometimes you
just need someone to listen to you that
knows what they're talking about that
can
help you
stop the spin and realize that your
anxiety is useless and not helping you
in any way right and better help is just
that it's online therapy you you can be
matched with a therapist in just under
48 hours there's a journal feature that
i love it's affordable
um and you guys like there is no shame
in getting your mental game in check and
it's hard to train your brain to be in
problem-solving mode
when like a challenge comes up but when
you learn how to find your own solutions
there's no better feeling and a
therapist is definitely someone that can
help you become a better problem solver
and make it easier to accomplish your
goals no matter how big or small like
sometimes
i need a little help just to figure out
how to i mean i still haven't learned
how to make my bed but we'll get there
maybe this week in therapy when you want
to be a better problem solver therapy
can get you there visit betterhelp.com
trash tuesday today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help help dot
com slash trash tuesday do you guys ever
find yourself not being able to find a
freaking cancel a subscription
oh
all the time hidden always it's also
i will remember i'll wake up in the
middle of the night and be like oh my
god
what i signed up for that thing and i
can't find it and i literally can't find
it on any of my apps i don't know where
it is but i know i'm spending the money
on it i will sign up for any streamer to
watch a show and then i'll forget
and then i'll have that subscription for
years and now i it's a waste i had an
insect identifier
for three years and what is that what is
it
it's a june bug
i had um
i had a subscription to an anime
streaming site that my niece apparently
had signed up for didn't know i had that
for three years
basically are you guys wasting money on
subscriptions because we know you are
eighty percent of people have
subscriptions that they forgot about
including everyone in this room
maybe it's for your unused amazon prime
or hulu that you never stream anything
on there's this amazing app that we use
and it helps us keep track of all of our
expenses and because
of it we don't waste money on unwanted
subscriptions like we used to rocket
money can find subscriptions you didn't
know you were paying for you may even
find out you've been double charged for
a subscription annie i know you know
that i know that pain
all you have to do is press cancel and
rocket money takes care of the rest and
you might remember they used to be
called true bill now they're called
rocket money cancel unnecessary
subscriptions with rocket money today go
to rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday seriously it could save
you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday
at the sex parties does it ever happen
where you have sex with a person you
just met like is that what they're
hoping because
because that's what she's saying
are you coming out as a day is that what
they hope for i'm just gonna say if i
was an old man and i'm paying hundreds
of thousands of dollars i'm going to
[ __ ] someone i'm meeting there i think
that that's what some guys probably hope
but i also know like a lot of these men
bring the women they want to [ __ ] there
so they're bringing women and then i
also know a lot of guys go because
they're really horny but they're super
timid so like they just want to watch
there's a lot of men that are watching
so all men that go in there already pay
a premium you cannot just bring a like
say for instance i can't just bring a
date there's one party that you can and
it's like uh 1500 so he already has to
be a member so everybody's every single
person that had to be approved as a
member so like if i wanted to bring a
boyfriend i would have him apply as a
member and then i could pay the 1500
couples ticket price and bring him along
with me does he have to like show his
dick in the app yeah exactly
what are you working with
i think they literally have too many of
those we need more of these they
definitely don't ask for nudes but i
know they asked like a full body picture
in a face photo but i don't think
they're turning now do you go in do you
see different like hair trends when you
go in like
yeah yeah because in porn it's like
everything under the sun yeah there's
just full bushes there's full nude yeah
dazzled there's everything yeah i like
bedazzled
and it's a lot
i didn't know so many porn people
even though the first time i went to a
sex party i met like i was talking to
all the porn stars that were performing
and that's where i really started
thinking oh my god i could like like i
started seeing into the world of porn
which is such a kind of an underworld
honestly of the normal world like no one
knows what goes on
in the sex communities at all unless
you're in it so i started learning about
it i was like oh my god these people
have really nice lives they're similar
to me like for the first time in my life
i'm meeting people who sex is
a hobby to and it's something a passion
and it's something they want to get
better at and that's something they want
to learn more about
and also they're making a ton of money
they have good relationships with people
who are just like them they live in nice
neighborhoods their kids go to nice
schools i was like i didn't know they
were just among us you know
and so then i started learning that and
it became so much more normalized to me
and i was like i can do this then of
course i did my research and at the same
time at the beginning of kovid only fans
was blowing up and i was like oh [ __ ]
like i'm only this young for so long
and at the same time i was already
having anal every day and i was i had a
secret tick tock account where i was
venting about all the anal i was having
all this stuff i was learning and i was
like praying no one found it before i
could go to med school
and then
it was just like this it was a coping
mechanism for sure it was like i had to
i had to vent or like release something
it was an outlet for you it really
wasn't out for all that i have a
question um
what are the chances that some mid 30 um
women
can still
emit
pushing over 30.
um
really really um
you know um see a career and only fans
like could we soar yeah or have we
missed the ship have you missed the boat
i mean i think that to have a long-term
career it's like it's easy it's best for
girls when they start at 18 and
literally just like make it as long as
possible but also
and i wish i could have started 18 but i
couldn't have like i was not ready
so
while that is the best because you can
make the most money you can literally
enter at any time like milks are just as
big
as like cute young girls like milfs are
huge they make so much money and so many
women blow up as milfs like do you guys
know who angela white is
angela white has been in porn for like i
think 11 years
and she's i think she's like 37 38 look
see her giant titties so hot super horny
milf um category you have to have big
tits because my um a girl she got into
the milf category but then she got right
after she got the implants so is that
like a prerequisite i don't think it's a
prerequisite because because i'm out
like little i think the the only thing
is to be horny honestly like it's just
having this natural horny vibe that you
can feel yeah and some guys like big
fake titties other guys just like
natural bodies of course if you have big
natural titties it's like a million
followers overnight yeah immediately
yeah there is nothing better than
big titties and like they're so rare you
know
so
angela white is a perfect example though
in the last year she has blown up to be
right now maybe the highest paid porn
star like mainstream porn star and also
probably making bank on her only fans
and uh
and those are real tits and she's been
doing yeah they're real she's amazing
but she's been doing porn forever and it
was she was never very big you know like
never like a main girl and now she is
like the biggest those are amazing do
you have advice if there was like a
young lady out there who was gonna start
and only fans like do you have like pro
tips that like things you wish you knew
or obviously it's probably like anything
else you learn as you do it yeah but if
there's any
i would say i mean i've
really just taught myself as i've gone
along but the main thing is to do don't
think you need someone else i think if i
had entered the industry 18 i would have
thought everyone else knows how to make
a successful business i have no clue
what the [ __ ] i'm doing but after
graduating college
i realized oh my god i'm one of the
smarter people in the world like i'm
capable of running a business it's not
that hard and so now when i get scammers
every single day in my dms like i can
help you make more money i'm like you
honestly can't like it's they all they
do is steal your money agencies and like
girls can do it on their own
they can hire people if they need to and
they can make a business by themselves
they don't need to like give away 20 or
50 percent to a manager or an agent or
and you're like the andrew schultz
it's like so many
yeah there's just so many parallels to
comedy like do you look back on your
like
your first videos like oh man this is
like an open mind
i should never have posted this i had to
have so many flops to have like my few
viral moments and that's what people
will look at me now like some of my
friends or girls in industry they're
like oh you just got lucky though like
you're just naturally good at this i'm
like honestly i have never felt good at
this like i have never felt like i knew
i was sexual
but i had to make a huge mockery of
myself and and actually enjoy doing it
and learn how to just embrace all my
flops which i think is probably the same
as comedy because then you get three i'm
[ __ ] going on yeah it's like you
wrong so many times you're like it
doesn't even hurt and then you kind of
break through that exactly if you think
you've made a mockery of yourself
check out me esther and my uh laugh
factory videos
don't have to have that unleash
you have to have that you have to have
first of all you have to write the come
up story everybody like wants to start
at the top but you don't gain a loyal
following if you don't have a come up
story from the literal bottom i knew
that too did you choose to do like was
it like part of your game plan to do
more like taboo um porn or was it more
like a natural
i think it was like
the only i think to be successful at
something you have to enjoy doing it
because it's gonna be especially
creating your own business it's like
every single day all day long you have
to do this stuff and i couldn't have
made
tick tocks every single day for the last
three years or two and a half years
about anal if i didn't actually do it
every day and like love it same with
only fans i i didn't i knew i wouldn't
be successful if i was playing a
character or like trapped in a character
that couldn't evolve so i just had to be
myself and even before i decided to do
porn i was already doing those anal tick
tock videos right and then started
blowing up and then people were like do
you even only fans
and so it just became my brand
and i was already doing anal every day
for a year before i even started and
only fans and then in the beginning i
was just like posting little bikini
pictures and then i started doing
butthole pictures and i slowly like
ramped up but the whole time it was
always about me loving anal because
that's my natural niche like
i don't have big titties i don't have
i don't have like
any niche when you look at me other than
maybe like natural american girl next
door
so anal just became my niche because
you're the national you're the girl back
door yeah
exactly
the girl back door i should that should
be a podcast name yeah well
okay so
when you are you in a relationship i am
and then when
like have you ever like started dating
someone and they're like do you like
save anal is anal for work is anal for
pleasure is anal for everything so
the relationship i'm in now it's an open
relationship but he is the one who took
my anal virginity oh okay and we
had anal on the first date okay i love
it yeah in the back of his car okay
and what kind of car is like the best
nissan rogue okay a robe
yeah big car anal on the first date yeah
and he was also homeless so his car was
his house
and it was honestly the best night of my
life like it was so good because i was
always sexually
explore explorative yeah um and i was
already going to sex parties and stuff
and i just wanted somebody that was
more sexually experienced to teach me
new things and that was finally someone
did i was like yes finally how did you
meet him
i was working at a homeless shelter for
veterans when i was at ucla listen
homeless guys are hot i [ __ ] a
homeless person that was great sex i'm
not even kidding i got banged out so
hard by a homeless guy crazy guys he was
so good he was so homeless julian you
did have that that's right
but i think that's what you said about
true right was that um he at that time
was choosing to be homeless yeah i mean
as much as a manic person chooses right
right yeah he was
he was like working as a waiter in south
carolina where he'd grown up his whole
life and he really wanted to be a poet
he wanted to leave his hometown and at
the same time he's bipolar manic and he
got super manic one day and just left
his whole life drove across the whole
country in like two days ended up in la
went to the va and was like hey like
what do i do and they just sent him to
the homeless shelter i worked at and i
checked him in and like showed him his
bed didn't think anything of it he was
young and pretty hot but i i didn't
think anything of it and then six months
go by of us getting to know each other
and he's just like the most genius funny
amazing person would you find her
[ __ ] kind of like wedding up when you
saw him no literally like butt giggling
i didn't know that my butthole wanted
him but it did
it was so horny for him like no one i've
ever had before probably because it was
forbidden yeah and also he was so
ruggedly hot like he was one of the
first men i've ever actually just looked
at and felt like he's attractive yeah i
have to know their personalities and
stuff but he was an ex-marine super in
shape blonde and blue eyes also manic so
he's like super funny walks in every
room and like tells stories was he like
really smart
yeah exactly
it brightens our eyes like homeless guys
with blue eyes you're like oh my god and
he's wearing a fedora with a with a
feather in it and i'm like this man just
followed no social convention you ask
him how his day is he's like living the
dream
like a pet goat i feel like i've got
this guy
no but is he homeless julian i wish he
did
and i just like it was so hot to me i
was like i could be homeless with this
man and i would be happy like it was
fine then of course
i started [ __ ] him it was a blast and
then he had his first depressive episode
went to the psych unit and i was like oh
this isn't
all fun and games all the time yeah
still the most genius person i've ever
met though
and he's been with me throughout my
whole like we were doing anal every
single day because he's an anal freak so
he really brought me into it
for a whole year before i even started
only fans and then i started [ __ ] him
for only fans and everything too i heard
you say somewhere that the if you want
to have the best sex of your life
[ __ ] a
homeless
veteran who has bipolar
literally crazy like you have to be
crazy a little bit of mental illness
right to be crazy in bed like it's just
well the term pull her is in his
literally just extremes it's like in him
you have to be you have to be broke like
broke eyes just [ __ ] better they do it's
like you're gonna give them a sandwich
i'm telling you i can't really know what
you're saying literally i really like it
well one i think it's because survival
all they have to offer to women right
like they're not paying for [ __ ] they're
not doing anything else so like i'm
gonna dick you down and you're gonna
fall in love
[Laughter]
and also i think it's like a coping
mechanism like or maybe it's just that
guys who are super horny are broke i
don't know yeah maybe that's what
they're doing they can't focus on making
money like exactly yeah like eight hours
they can't go like nine you're like
flowering every girl's butthole and they
just can't really work because of that
yeah they're deflating and then also
older older so he is 10 years older than
me
older guys
know how to [ __ ] like they just do i
i've [ __ ] a few younger guys in the
last few years and
they they can't even stay hard well how
old are you because they're nervous and
intimidated by me and stuff whereas
older guys they're just like they know
what to do i have a theory that men
should have to stay virgins until
they're 30 because they're wasting we
would have literal war
every school will get shot up
for real for real men nutting is like
the only thing that keeps peace in the
world
and like if you make a man not like when
when drew was was getting like manic or
depressed i would just give him blow
jobs every single morning and he'd be so
happy
they're nice and wears otherwise they're
really guys get really aggressive if
they're not nutting
you're right but right to hell with your
theory yeah with men under their 30s is
so bad like we should be paying away not
always i know that's not all that's
right always he's very sensitive
i went from old to young and i was so
grateful this is what happens with men
when they're young the milfs [ __ ] them
and the milfs teach them everything they
know yeah right
and then when they get in their 30s they
[ __ ] the 20 year olds yeah but all these
guys in their 20s one they they're horny
enough that they love to [ __ ] like 40 50
60 year old women and the 40 56 year old
women love it and teach them everything
and then when men are in their 30s they
[ __ ] the younger girls or the girls
their age it's literally every guy that
i've had sex with that's happening
so when dave passes away
he's ten years older than me and he's
not in the beginning
and he has sleep apnea we just find his
mask was taken off one night
i need it's my job to have sex with like
young men and teach them exactly we're
back to mentally that's what happens for
women too like
20 men in their 20s and women in their
20s [ __ ] the opposite sex or the same
sex in their 40s right yeah and then
when when women and men get in their 30s
they kind of they start [ __ ] each
other dating each other i [ __ ] like 10
years older when i was in my 20s which
was exactly it was good because it felt
like uh like we were having stars like
yeah they were like taking and it was
like taking me on excursions the the the
milfs and the dilfs are like teaching
the 20 year olds how to [ __ ] yeah yeah i
think this is big yeah this is real this
is a thing every single man i've ever
met has [ __ ] milfs in his 20s and no
girls know this i feel like but if you
ask him about it you're right i i don't
think i've met a guy who hasn't been um
with a woman in her 40s when he was in
yeah
yeah i can't think because the women are
horny for that and they're divorced or
something they need it
and the young guys are like yeah this is
[ __ ] hot like even bobby um bobby
when he was in his 20s he hooked up with
a woman in her late 50s and he [ __ ]
her in um the grandma van where she had
her grandkids toys in the
trunk
oh i thought you meant you like had like
the stuffed animals and the like
you know like just the
animals like oh
that's crazy
she had like her grandkids like like
tricycle in the back and he um i guess
she like went to one of his shows and i
guess kevin christie was like dude she's
pretty like she's a hot milf he was like
okay
and so he went for it and he said it was
so fun
yeah yeah and i think he hooked up with
her like twice not just having christie
banger like why was he
i have no idea
he's like a yenta
i don't know if it was i think it was
kevin christie but um i think that um
yeah i think you're right it's the
infallible theory i swear like at least
maybe successful men are men that are
good in bad [ __ ] milfs
and that's why also when girls are like
oh men only like girls that look like
they're 12.
it's like honestly
milf porn is freaking huge
and
every guy i know
loves older women wants to [ __ ] older
women so there's hope for us yeah well i
think the ones that get in trouble
they're like the really troubled men are
the ones that are attracted to the young
girls those are the ones that are yeah
there's always people on the front lines
and a good life like that yeah like
nothing's enough yeah the older we're
talking about the healthy the mentally
okay men right now that's like a whole
genre is the oldest for younger sorry
yeah yeah i think everybody wants the
thing that is different than them yeah
that's a good point yeah you want
something different
all right guys neutral is working i'm so
sorry i am a skeptic and but it is
working it's my hair is thickening up
i've had the thinnest hair forever it's
growing in it it looks really good i've
known you for 10 years this is the best
your hair has ever looked it works and i
don't know what to say
the proof is in the
um lack of extensions also the proof is
in the fact that they're not promising
an overnight fix oh yeah duh i've been
taking neutral for years you guys and
there was one point after i stopped
birth control where i was like oh my god
i only have like half of my hair left if
it wasn't for neutrophil i would be
an emotional mess because hair is really
important for me to look pretty hair is
really important i mean i can speak to
that the time that i had my hair chopped
off against my will and it also that
sent me into a depression and then me
into depression because i had to hear
about it
but you wrote some really great jokes
about it and the fact is 30 million
women are impacted by weekend or
thinning hair if you're among them know
that you're not alone and there is a
solution you can trust to deliver
results and just hang in there like i i
promise you i was a skeptic i take it
every day four pills
it works i can't believe it my
hairdresser was like annie this is
insane i'm like
in fact in a clinical study 86 of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months also i was just in italy with a
bunch of hot girls and we saw [ __ ] they
were talking about neutral everyone cool
uses nutrifoal like it really is the one
thing that's not a gimmick that everyone
knows works
neutral is the number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth thickness and visible scalp
coverage neutrophil supports healthy
hair growth from within by targeting the
five root causes of thinning
of thinning stress hormones environment
nutrition and metabolism through a whole
body health and neutrophil has three
unique formulas to support women
throughout all stages of life including
postpartum and menopause each formula is
physician formulated using natural
drug-free medical grade ingredients and
consistently effective dosages so you
get the most reliable results over 3000
pop doctors and stylists recommend
neutral as an effective and high quality
solution for healthier hair
you guys can grow thicker healthier hair
and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com and entering the promo
code trash to save 15 off your first
month subscription this is our best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time plus
free shipping on every order get 15 off
at nutrafull.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
promo code annie what is it trash
um you said something on your podcast
with sophia with an f
that really blew my freaking mind now
you were talking about just the maternal
instinct of a woman and i always thought
i was void of this
maternal instinct because i never really
wanted to have children but you were
saying that in itself is a maternal
instinct to kind of um
not rush into
um bringing a child into the world that
you're not sure about yeah to like know
what's best for your child if that even
means not bringing them in
ever right your environment or because
you don't feel like it will be right you
know like that's why women don't have
kids they don't feel like they'll be a
good mom they don't feel like their life
is conducive to it they don't feel like
they want it that's all i always think
that's always a maternal that's my
personal theory i just came up with it
like over years of watching
nature documentaries about animals and
i've always thought that especially when
i got my abortion that was something i
was thinking about how old were you i
was 17
and uh in my first year of college
and
i remember just i was so sure and my mom
being a doctor too who's performed
abortions like i always knew they
weren't bad
like they weren't it was
a smart thing to do at least that's how
my mom phrased it to me if i felt that
it was right like she had two abortions
before she had me and then my brother
and so i was always saw it as like i i
know i want to have kids in the future
but i know it's 17 right now with this
guy like this is not the time for my
children and especially after i had
the abortion i had this just i could
couldn't process how i felt for months
right and i
i i felt so different and my whole life
changed in terms of like what i
prioritized and it was some kind of
weird feeling about
want realizing i don't want to be this
person when i do have a kid and the
woman i want to be when i do have a
child and kind of becoming that so it
was like a wake-up call to me a little
bit
and so ever since then i've always kind
of thought that and i never really
because it's like recently you feel a
lot of times i've felt less of a woman
because i've not had this like you know
deep burning feeling to like
bring my spawn onto the earth right i've
had you know abortions when because i
didn't think it was the correct time for
my body or for my relationship at that
time but i always thought i was a little
bit less or i lacked that instinct when
in reality i might that is an instinct
that is still very much
and it's like something our you know our
thoughts don't don't just exist for no
reason
all the thoughts that we have and our
decision-making skills and how our brain
is wired is based on survival and you
know the survival of our children and if
our children survived more of those
traits you know are passed down so
there's a reason that you're thinking
these things and i don't think people
realize that is that it's all an
instinct and when you're watching
lion mothers keep their babies away from
society for like three weeks or three
months until they feel that it's time
and safe enough for them to be
introduced into their community and
society i feel like women
can do or do the same thing maybe even
since we have
even more consciousness i guess you
could say or conscious decision-making
power we can do that before we even get
pregnant right in terms of like timing
when is right for our children to enter
into society because it's always a math
equation in my head right it's like how
how are my genetics going to unfold here
you know there's a lot of addiction and
mental illness and people don't think
that that's an instinctual kind of thing
but i've always felt horrible for not
for basically calculating these things
because if a man wants to have a child
with you automatically you should be
like yes but it's like all of these
things that i have considered over time
has made me feel pretty shitty for not
just bringing life onto this earth yeah
so thank you for saying that in itself
is something that is totally maternal
it's hard i want to do it right and
that's why i've been trepidatious my
whole life and like what more can we
trust than the maternal instinct like
that is something that has literally
kept humanity and all other animals you
know alive and functioning and it's like
one of the best guiding forces
on where society should go and then
we're just gonna like [ __ ] on it and the
government's just gonna be like oh you
just have to have one if you you just
have to ignore all your freaking
thoughts and just have one yeah like if
you get pregnant that just makes no
sense to me when the maternal instinct
is such a
asset to
survival and evolution
yeah so yeah i i'm glad that you that
you saw thank you i found a lot of
relief i think a lot i think that about
like that applies to a lot of things i
think in terms of just listening to
yourself and learning to listen to your
voice and trusting that instinct and
figuring out why you're thinking these
things because i don't think that we
you know have thoughts for no reason i
think it's all for a reason right i
don't think she's the smartest in the
room i think she might be the most
emotionally intelligent as well
healthy you guys are really flattering
me i do feel like when i was in my early
30s i did not want to have kids like i
was like i don't have kids i'm focusing
my career and when i realized i got into
a relationship where a lot of like my
stuff came up
and i was so angry and i just remember
thinking like if i don't deal with this
anger like that's why i can't be a
mother like it's like it's like i'm
gonna like take this out on my kid and
it's just not worth it right for me to
take like how my dad used to treat me
and do that and then so then i worked on
myself and now i froze those [ __ ] and
we'll see later but it is like
it was i realized like my being like i
don't want to be a mom wasn't
necessarily as like i was so sure i
remember older women would be like
you'll change your mind and i would get
so mad because i was like you know what
i'm going to change my mind and i don't
think every
woman decides but i do think it was that
same sort of thing you were saying but
you're right annie like i'm i'm changing
my mind like every day that passes i'm
feeling more and more like oh i can do
this even alone yeah i can do this i
always used to never feel like i could
do it even with an entire community
behind me that's how unready i was
but now it's like i'm getting to that
point where it's like i can do this
alone and i feel strong in that like i
trust who i am i trust you know in my
skills to parent to love someone to
share my life with this growing thing so
i didn't feel that way years ago the
thing i relate to that you said about
after your abortion you realized that
you weren't
the person you wanted to be as a mom so
for me last year i had a miscarriage and
i had that same thing i was like wait
i'm so grateful this happened because i
wasn't ready yeah and now i feel like
okay i need to become the person i want
to be so that i will feel ready at one
point and so it's really that like
changed my whole perspective on my whole
life it's literally transformative and
that's what i was processing for so long
i was like why do i feel different
and i realized that's the first time i
felt my maternal instinct like i really
felt it and i acted on it and then i
realized wow this is kind of what
motherhood
is about like i'm now realizing what i
want to be as a mom and i'm going to
take those steps to get there there's
something about becoming pregnant that i
just you're like
you just see your body it's just so
different i literally thought i was an
alien like i was looking at myself like
i was [ __ ] so pretty
oh my god for six weeks
i was the prettiest i'd ever felt so i
have some like heart issues and some
weird autoimmune stuff all of those went
away my skin was flawless i was tired a
lot but i was like should i just keep
going because i'm [ __ ] stunning right
you just become a surrogate and you're
just always pregnant because you're just
like i just feel best the offer stands
i was mad sick like i was crazy so i
like it was the day after four weeks
from conception so like literally the
first day of my like missed period i was
like basically one day pregnant you know
i hate that and when they do the dnc
they're just going there blindly like i
hope we get all of this they can't see
it they couldn't see one thing so
they've had a vacuum around a time but i
was so ill like that's how i knew that i
was pregnant because i was i don't know
how i knew honestly but i was in a cab
on the way home from school and i was
like i'm gonna throw up out of the side
of this car like i had never felt that
kind of nausea before i went home i had
an old pregnancy test from like early
call like the first week of college from
my roommate i it was probably expired
and i used it and i was like oh my god
i'm pregnant booked the abortion for 8
a.m the next morning and the next
morning the next morning i was i didn't
tell anyone i was so deathly ill the
whole it was torture the whole time i
was waiting in the waiting room at
planned parenthood i was like i'm gonna
throw up in the trash can i am going to
throw up in the trash can it's gonna be
so [ __ ] embarrassing like i've never
felt sicker in my life wow it was so bad
and it didn't imagine they did like
judge you they're like it would you just
puke it yeah and i was like
i think i'm gonna throw up and the lady
was like it's too late right now to give
you medicine to like make you not
nauseous because we have to take you in
but she was like you won't be the first
person that's thrown up on the table
she's like it's not gonna come out that
way we
and then of course i realized like you
don't even feel the nausea when you're
just well because i was alone i didn't
tell anybody so i didn't even have
anesthesia or anything so i just had
local numbing like creams i've been
there um
you can't really feel fear in that
moment when there's only one option and
you feel so sick anyway
so i was just like laying there just had
to i've always been kind of tough like
that though i was like i'm not gonna die
so it was so painful for me because i
opted oh you passed out i fully passed
out okay because so so what i did was i
opted for the raw dog um yeah just drawn
as well
they can put you under twilight sedation
right where you're kind of in you're
kind of out but you don't generally feel
the pain it's a very short procedure
it's like under five minutes of the
actual vacuuming but i was like oh no
problem i can do this oh my [ __ ] god
right oh my [ __ ] god the pain of even
the minute and a half it took to
actually like highlights like twilight
yeah in and out it's twilight sedation
they give you like valleys it's a little
you're not like fully assisted i don't
know like how romantic they are they're
like making you think about vampires and
there's like there's like stars on the
ceiling twilight they're like
vampires
watching twilight and while it's going
on they put fangs on you before you go
out i highly recommend you get yourself
a colonoscopy and see how it feels
oh yeah
like i'm addicted to the feeling well
that's what michael jackson was hooked
on was um one of the drugs that they
give you when you go under for
colonoscopies it's a very short acting
i'm still hooked on my wisdom teeth uh
laughing gas i enjoyed that a lot i've
never had any anything like that like
i've never had any
anesthesia anesthesia
anything because i've never had like a
surgery like this
like general anesthesia yeah exactly
yeah i've never even taken like valium
or anything yeah they give you
do you think that having that abortion
at such a young age
like
changed the course of your life in like
a big way a small way
probably a big way wow for the better
for sure just because one i realized
okay i can't [ __ ] around with birth
control anymore like i need to make sure
i'm on the [ __ ] cuz one i was taking a
short break between pills because i
can't take birth control pills they all
just make me sick and so i was taking
like a month break before i tried a new
one and i was also on my period having
shower sex with my college boyfriend
then that's what i got pregnant from on
your period yeah i have period sex
that's what i constantly have that's the
only time i'm comfortable
i'm so scared of getting pregnant
so i was like okay one that's when you
became an is this how it changed your
life you became the anal girl yeah it's
a lot easier i wish i started anal then
honestly because then still the rest of
college i had
yeast infections utis and bv like every
single time i had sex like i am a girl
i'm a chronic baby i'm a chronic
yes that's always a cycle too it goes
from bv to yeast yeah it's always just a
chronic [ __ ] never ending science tv
is just the rough one because you can't
hide it yeah it just smells like crap
you know what there is there is a girl
at spin class that i go to who i kind of
admire her but hate when i sit next to
her she clearly has bv it's a very
distinct smell i know it i know it too
because you're sitting there and you
crazy smell it's almost a creamy fish
there's like a great cream no
creamy element crazy about this i was
sitting in a hotel the other day and i
had room service next to me and i had a
caesar salad with anchovies on it
sitting there because i'm sitting there
watching tv not eating anymore and i'm
like oh my god do i have bv
i'm touching my [ __ ] and i'm like
smelling i'm like where the [ __ ] is that
coming from and i thought it was me and
then i look over and it's the caesar
salad i was like oh that's exactly it
but i think that i kind of
so this girl it's been flash she clearly
has chronic bv it's not something that's
a one-and-done she's a girl to tell her
are you gonna but i think she knows some
people don't want to take the meds
though some people don't want to take
she doesn't want to take the meds
but i think she's one of those girls
that kind of just owns it she knows it's
something that she's cr that's chronic
[ __ ] that she has to deal with but she
doesn't stop her life for it and i
really [ __ ] respect it because it's
like who cares at that point she's
living with bv maybe she wants a little
[ __ ]
life maybe she wants a little space and
she knows there's going to be a little
bit of an area around her she just got a
bubble literally she's got a bubble
she's got her own bubble yeah that's a
good point it is like an exercise in
people like getting over people pleasing
if you're just
watching out everywhere you go literally
just let it happen because it is just
whatever it is what ketamine just get
beavy
we're going to insert bv and deer
[ __ ] uv is the [ __ ] worst but it
is easily fixable at least i think
although i technically have like chronic
bv where every time or every other time
a guy goes inside my [ __ ] i get bv like
it just any uncut
you know
that's easy central like i think that's
not talked about enough is when you have
a mismatch of like a floor your flora
with a guy and there are partners that
i've had where every single time it was
one of the three either uti yeast or
something you know like a bacterial
infection and there are partners where
it's just our codes just match and i've
never never gotten like any type of
digings
do you think it's the codes match or
just that they shower appropriately i
think it's a codes map yeah it is
because it's even like people a lot of
times think that yeast infections or bv
happen because someone's like dirty yeah
but it's really or even utis but it's
really just like you have very sensitive
bacteria in your your vaginal flora is
just so easily offset and with just
someone foreign going in there with
their own flora of their you know
genitals which can't it isn't bad it
just offsets it well it's like even if i
even if i were to wear non-cotton
panties for an hour
it's over for wow yeah it just offsets
your ph yeah
women are like literally our bodies just
want us to get pregnant the first time
we have sex and never have sex again
it's like we're not meant to have like
daily breaking down or just even though
i want it so bad well i was thinking
that today because i'm on my period and
it's obviously hell and i'm like do we
get periods so that we'll get pregnant
because i'm like i want this to stop do
you want to know the cravings
you know the craziest theory that my
brother learned in one of his nyu
classes
the the main theory of why women pms
and why they get periods or why they pms
before their period right and they get
really moody
and all these other issues is to cause
animosity in a couple that's unfertile
so it's to break up infertile pair bonds
so if you're not my parents were not
supposed to be together yeah
like i remember my dad like banging on
the table and something like this has to
stop because my bms was so
you must go to a doctor that's literally
what nature intended
it's because like if okay say the the
man
is infertile or the woman's infertile
it's gonna cause animosity every month
that they're fighting and she's not
pregnant because she's getting pms over
and over and it's causing animosity so
they break up and go find people that
they can be fertile with and so it
basically forces you to go away from
people and break up bonds with people
that you can't get pregnant with because
what are you yeah you shouldn't because
nature you're not gonna put up with that
monthly
you know um um warfare yeah if if if the
person you're that's across you isn't
going to produce um offspring exactly
and it's like if they are producing
offspring all the time they're not
having that monthly warfare right and
that is menopause to just make men find
younger women
i honestly think like we just weren't
playing we you know our bodies started
dying like we just weren't supposed to
live this long mine been dead girl
we're supposed to become the old like
witches to like you know raise the
younger women yes not have babies
anymore oh yeah because that probably is
it it's like oh you have higher chances
of having you know babies with issues so
it's like push the men away
and every woman in menopause is like
divorcing their husband became dr wong
they changed it all and now we can all
freeze them up because older women are i
mean i would say they're the best moms
because like the
women in my family have kids 18 and then
the like my mom who had me at 37
both amazing moms yeah but older women
like are amazing moms girls well your
mom obviously is great like your mom
taught you to like trust yourself and
from what i'm getting maybe i'm no my
mom is amazing and and
for her it was because she waited to
have her whole career and was
financially stable and with someone she
loved and knew it was time to bring a
kid in the world and so i've i had the
most amazing childhood and so i always
have known i want to do the same thing
i'm pmsing i'm like about to cry yeah
oh my pms is so bad i literally am on
lexapro
i i started
with in the beginning i would only take
it the seven days before my period
because i would go i would go so insane
yeah i have pre-menstrual dysphoria i
just get so emotional i just get so like
like sensitive i get like nice oh yeah
no i'm i'm
i'm a crazy banana
[Music]
i would say 99 of men love [ __ ] like
and i would say 199 percent of women
love it but also everyone [ __ ] i look
like in my life it's like i was a baby
[ __ ] like i can't even imagine
another like the other option was to be
called a [ __ ] and screamed at by
guys that way too it was like i never
felt like
just it yeah i'm like what the hell but
now i it's like all about accepting
myself and not seeing those things but
it's just like those comments have just
been like hitting me recently where i'm
like what the hell's and i don't know
where it came up with this thing where
it's like it's either the comment is
like women aren't funny or
all women talk about his sex on stage
and it's like all guys talk about a sex
on stage or whatever they talk about or
who cares it's just like so weird it's
just like you know what's funny is like
guys talk about sex off stage and in a
[ __ ] disgusting they don't want to
talk about it in public because they're
trying to [ __ ] you it's like
it'll give away what they're trying to
do to the audience or whatever i think
like a life-changing thing for me was
when i realized that every single man
whether he's an in-cell and he hates
women or like loves women any every man
takes all his actions based off women
like men are terrified of women and men
dress how they dress they they change
their personalities all to
deal with this like fear and and
yearning for for women yeah
and um
and so it's like if men are hating on
you it's probably it's it's it's because
they are like they want [ __ ]
and it drives men to some crazy length
and i was thinking about it but it's so
true if they're getting triggered by
like girls talking about sex it's like
they're probably thinking like you
[ __ ] everyone but me like you know
like you brought bubble gum and there
wasn't enough for me yeah you gave it to
everyone in the class like me women
these days suck and it's really because
they can't get women so they're just
sitting there like well why let me just
let me just project onto them and say
it's their fault when really i just wish
someone would look at me lovingly and
like take my dick out i know just
like it's so pathetic like
any single man you honestly can get you
can get them to to break down that wall
like even the craziest woman hater if
you're just like you know well also it's
like accepting and loving and i want to
love your penis i'm also just like is
your mommy like what's going on with
your mommy yeah like when i was so mad
how do you feel like literally just
just uh give them some attention some
one-on-one time for a little while and
every man will just become nicer this is
why men need to nut men that are not
nutting become
filled with hatred you know what i'm
gonna um start a summer program when you
drop dudes off literally turbo jerk i'm
telling you and he does a perfect
there's a shower there's a shower this
is at the end of my relationships i
always start doing the turbo jerk where
i just have to like
i had seen blackfish and you know how
like
telecom they had to jerk off telecom so
he wouldn't kill the whale
so i would just i had this boyfriend who
i just didn't like i couldn't face him i
couldn't even let him look at the back
of my head i just couldn't do it anymore
but i would just
wait he'd be in the shower and i
wouldn't even be looking at him i would
give him the turbo jerk
and my main it would be like wet my arm
would be like wet you were literally
folding your whole body out of the
relationship yeah
i gotta let you and he was still like
i'm just going to ride this guy because
he probably leaves like completely
broken
so he had to walk in on me crying one
day
and i was like all right i gotta break
up with you i've literally had that
experience like most of my younger
relationships i i wanted to leave them
and i was not courageous just enough to
wait i know and so i would be like i
remember the first time i ever had to
drink so i could physically stomach
giving my boyfriend a [ __ ] oh that's
how i like started i was like i need to
break up with him but we are on our one
year anniversary trip in hawaii and i
can't break up with him now
and i can't i literally would have vomit
if i even look at his penis because i'm
so not into him anymore and i drank to
do it i was at disney going can you dump
a guy on his birthday at disneyland with
his mom that's always where i was like
oh what am i doing because i just was
like i would never be here in a million
years and anyone who loved me would
never take me with their family with no
children to [ __ ] disneyland like they
would know who i was as a person that's
exactly how i felt on the hawaii trip i
was like this is i hate this you know i
just have to ride this out because i
can't do it now but that's when it gets
so bad that you just do it anyway like
literally the day we got home from the
hawaii trip i broke up with him and
never spoke to him again mm-hmm he's
probably like you with the disneyland
and he's probably fine yeah when i broke
up with the guy and then he like cried a
lot and i did feel guilty but i felt so
happy at finally oh yeah you feel so
guilty but then you're sorry but it's
like the guilt only lasts like one week
and then you're like yeah freedom and
even if you feel guilty it's so worth it
it's better than having no always you
shouldn't it's like
well one time i was gonna break up with
him we were on a hike and we were
but like and he pulled me and like the
sun was setting he like pulled me out of
me like romantically and it was gone it
was gone it just like fell out of me
when he dipped me and i went i have no
love for this person anymore to do and
and i like it was just crazy it was
instant and then but we were going up
the mountain so i stayed with him
because i've been going down the
mountain i would have broken up with him
but i was like
wow so um that was that was a nick i
don't know when we did you know three
years later
and it's so pathetic you're like god
they don't even know
it wasn't
all it was like it just was like
you're not for me
right at all my ick was we were going on
a hike in the pacific palisades like one
a very nice neighborhood right home of
the army hammer's family yeah
the crazy old generation got to watch it
get to this and we're going to discover
it on this cute hike and we get like a
mile in and he's terrified of nature
and he's like we need to turn around
like i'm so scared i don't like it he's
like freaking out having his head
and i was like we are in the palisades
right now and i was just like i
i can't do this anymore like and then i
was like oh my god the hawaii trips in
one month what do i do
i have to stay for it because it's
already paid for i know there's so many
things like that where you're like you
can get out of anything like especially
i i love oh yeah
i'd be like peace out and i remember
feeling like this is like a divorce like
we're gonna have to like we know each
other's families you can get the [ __ ]
out of there you can get out of anything
you'll be fine exactly it always is so
daunting even like my mom got divorced
from my dad she's like god i wish i did
it 20 years earlier wow i always feel
like that yeah like why did i waste all
that time it only gets more complicated
yeah i have a question because you're a
very horny sexual girl and you're very
in touch with your sexuality and
confidence like do you have tips for
women who maybe like don't feel sexy but
want to or like want to get hornier any
like how to hype yourself up any kind of
things like that i would say one like
make sure you know how you orgasm like
that was the biggest thing for me is
like figuring out how to make myself
orgasm and orgasm every single day
because that's something like at least
for me i think probably a lot of girls
like this too like in college i didn't
have a vibrator once because i was like
oh my boyfriend doesn't want to buy toys
and i don't really want to like take the
leap and go to sex shops i'll just like
use my shower head sometimes or use my
my toothbrush
and so only after i broke up with him
after college was like i should get a
vibrator and then i started learning
like
how to make myself orgasm in 40 minutes
and then i started learning how to make
myself orgasm in 10 minutes and now it's
like i can almost make myself orgasm
just mentally yeah i was just going to
ask
because of all of that like internal
fantasizing and stuff while you're
orgasming i have unlocked so many of my
fantasies and what i find hot and what
makes me feel good when i think that's
like having sexual
literacy with yourself or understanding
is so helpful because then you start
being confident in your sexuality and
you're like oh i know what's hot
and i like know how to channel my sexual
energy when i'm with someone now how
does that translate sexual literacy when
you've been with someone long term
so i'm like a super long-term
relationship girl i'm always in
long-term relationships ever since i
literally lost my virginity at 13 that
was like a long-term relationship even
though we were children we were like
both best friends you know in sixth
grade and after
and uh
i think
long-term relationships and why i like
sex so much is because i am always
having sex with people i'm super
comfortable with so you can get super
kinky you can like teach them how to you
you just become more comfortable sharing
your sexuality with somebody else you
know when you're in like a relationship
with someone i think it's a lot harder
to get in touch with yourself sexually
with another person when you're not in a
long-term relationship because someone
you don't know i've been re-listening to
esther perel's ester perel's mating in
captivity
um and basically you know she talks
about people who
feel their sexual aliveness when they
are in this familiar safe space to kind
of just like you know act out on all
their kinks because they're like this
person i trust this person enough but
then there's another half of us where
um that safety and that intimacy and
that love and um the love takes away
from our sexual aliveness and i think
i'm one of those i think it's unhealthy
[ __ ] though i think kalila i think that
is because we were [ __ ] molested and
so we're like
we're used to using sex like when we
[ __ ] people and i'm just saying we
from what we like have been talk
discussed before but it's like we use
sex to like get attention kind of before
we used it we were trying to like be
something for other people i think it's
more that
like it was more like putting it on than
like i think that what happened
in a relationship is the beginning that
kind of otherness of someone that
uncertainty really brings out this like
sexual energy you know that is i'm so i
do everything to harness that i cannot
lose this so i start introducing the
idea of long-term relationship of love
of us being long-term partners because i
don't want to lose this brand new thrill
but what i'm actually doing is taking
away
now i'm like taking away from the one
thing i wanted to keep which is the
sexual aliveness once i'm in this
familiar safe harbor um i become less
horny and i think that's bobby said the
same thing where it's like as soon as we
became this force
together
we kind of wanted to like [ __ ] less and
because like
like basically astaire perel says two
cannot be one like you have no one to
connect with anymore when you become
that that that close with someone like
you go out to dinner and who are you you
have no one to connect with you're too
enmeshed and that's been my problem is
to maintain my otherness has been a
chronic issue in relationships i need to
be my own separate thing yeah introduce
a little bit of mystery even a little
bit of risk and adventure and then i
feel more like juiced up honestly i'm
the exact same way same and i think
especially because i no i'm not
including this i don't know you as well
but i think all three of us i would say
have the like we want to become one with
our partners and the only reason that i
escaped that is because dave
will not become one
but i think that and and maybe you have
this too like
that's just what our natural instinct is
we want all all of this give me all i'll
eat your [ __ ] no i'm like i will do
anything and let's be the closest two
people have ever been i don't know but i
love it i love it
but todd's so different from me too
that's what i love about him just the
way that he like interacts in the world
like i learned so much from him he's 11
years younger than me and it's like
he's 11 years old he's 11 years old
no but he really just like handles
things in a very different way than i do
and it's so like calming for me because
i'm such a psycho when i dated another
psycho it was like people will die like
someone is dead exactly cops were called
things were crazy and i just like i
don't know and i but i do think that
um yeah i don't know i feel like even
though we spend a lot of time together i
do feel like we're two different things
i don't feel as like unhealthy as i've
been with before but
um yeah i don't know i do that exact
same thing but you've you've um been um
in an open relationship right i think
that's why this has been my most
successful relationship in terms of me
just staying happy like i get bored
really fast with people and a big thing
is that the sexual thrill dies off and
i'm someone that needs that like i like
to get to know new people
through sex
and so
this is my first relationship or one the
person i'm dating is crazier than i am
and he's super sexual like super sexual
so no matter what happens with me like
he will always make sure we have sex
every single day and i'm so thankful for
that because i need someone to like in a
relationship when it's three years in to
make sure we're still like sexually
happy and i think a lot of women like
are really
i mean it's hard when the guy starts not
wanting to have sex
because
a horny for you right you're like also
kinky too like both ways though so i
need an initiator but i don't need a
beggar so yeah yeah you need someone
that just sticks it in like i need
someone to be like to kind of like read
my body a little better because i have
been in relationships where like the
dude needed to just drain his balls
every day and i just could not oh yeah
they're like can you blow me yeah and
it's like shut up shut up and it's like
this is
not seem as intuitive it's like i've
been into it but i [ __ ] you three
times already today like the fourth time
i'm not gonna be as excited as the
[ __ ] first time what the hell no drew
is like so good at like when we wake up
in the morning he'll just like roll me
over and he'll start we'll start having
anal and like i don't even have to
process it i don't have to think it's
your own clock and yeah and then it's
like i don't have to do anything he gets
off i get off and then i am super happy
the whole day i'm like yes i [ __ ] today
i'm i'm sexual and like he didn't sit
there and like can you below me this
morning like if the begging is annoying
you need a man that's naturally just so
insanely horny for you but i
i [ __ ] him all the time and it was it
just would it like and it hurt my
feelings when he would be like it's not
enough i'm like it is enough yeah it is
enough like it's it's like there's no no
no no no you're not like you're not
you're not compatible but he also sounds
like drew also just reads your cues yeah
yeah he knows you well enough to be like
hey because we're like the same sexually
yeah we just we really are so similar so
he we definitely like we're so similar
and that's i think why it works so well
even though he's super crazy i'm also
crazy in a lot of ways but then also he
respects me
and understands me so much that he
understands i want to [ __ ] other people
and i'm going to and i don't and i
couldn't stay in a relationship where i
couldn't because he
he's not the same way right now because
he's older but he was
like that in his all of his 20s and so
we're so similar he understands i need
that from my 20s he needed as well right
now he doesn't like he doesn't he could
sleep with other girls but he just is
lazy like he just he [ __ ] me and then
he's happy like he's not gonna go out
and try and find another girl would you
get a little jealous like in a good way
um
yeah probably because i i'm not like a
jealous type at all and i the thing
about like we have a lot of threesomes
together because i bring a lot of girls
over and
it is the craziest thing because we're
just best friends like we just
understand each other so well when i'm
watching him with another girl like when
i'm watching him [ __ ] another girl i'm
so proud i'm like yeah he [ __ ] so
[ __ ] good and then when i'm watching
another girl pleasure him or when we're
both like blowing him or she's blowing
him i'm looking at him like
oh
look at him like he deserves this he's
so sweet like i'm so like happy to see
him i think it's so cute when todd comes
i'm so sorry his sister
but it's like it is like so cute i'm
like you are just such an angel yeah and
i don't care if he's like we we
jerk off to like porn all the time
together and separately we [ __ ] girls
together he'll like not on other girls
he'll not two other girls like it
doesn't bother me like i know we're best
friends i know we understand each other
and have a connection so then it's like
sex is just so fun and it's so fun to
create situations where he is pleasured
yeah like that's a blast for me i'm
still shocked when i see
or hear about people who don't approve
of their partner watching porn right
they think that's like so weird it's
like it's like a lot of 14 year old
girls on tick tock it's like literally
they're 14 and they're like i will never
let my boyfriend watch well good luck
and i'm like
because honey on you
think about this right now because you
don't even understand the thing about
porn is like if you don't understand it
that's okay like it's not for everybody
not one industry is for everybody
and like it's not it's especially not
for you when you're that young like just
just wait you'll see that at some point
you might like watching it you might not
too we're a very pro porn household yeah
i'll say that
i love porn porn the thing about sex and
porn and everything is when it's at its
best at least it's play and right play
is so important
for humans right and i have a birth
control question so you said you don't
take the pills but what do you do so
i've had an iud ever since i got my
abortion in college okay all right i'm
not [ __ ] around anymore so i've had
like every single eye okay i started i
remember with the mirena
and so that's hormonal it's like the
standard kind of one in the middle and
it was too high of hormones for me i was
like super constipated i had back knee
it was so like i'm into anal i can't
have back nights
but then i did have regular periods so i
was like okay your iud turned you into
me
that's one of my biggest
that's why we issues
each other's yeah it was backed up and
acne and so then i got on a lower dose i
think it was the scylla
and that at the time was the lowest dose
of hormones in an iud and then i didn't
have acne i didn't have constipation but
it didn't regulate my period so then i
was just bleeding like randomly and all
the time and it was terrible so then i
got on the copper iud
and that's when i realized i hadn't been
off of birth control and had like a
regular cycle since i was like 13
and i didn't know what my cycle was like
and that's when i started having
premenstrual dysphoria because i same as
how my mom was when she was young were
very sensitive to hormones so i'm
literally psychotic and i go manic the
week before my period so then i had to
start lexapro while i was on the copper
iud
yeah and so then recently i got and i
think i'm uh
i think i have
kylina now and that's the iud i have now
and it's like kind of medium ground yeah
in terms of hormones and it's perfect
i'm so glad like i don't have any
constipation problems acne problems my
period has like in the beginning it was
just regular and now it's like
two days maybe a month yeah it's really
light okay so i'm an iud girly all the
way i have to ask a question that i've
been thinking
for a few minutes can she kiss you what
is make out what are the
fantasies that you have discovered that
help you orgasm oh my god if you would
you know what's so funny i've been
thinking about this a lot recently every
fantasy i have that i think about when i
come started as a dream
like i'll i'll have like not a wet dream
so obviously i don't ejaculate but the
the female comparison where i wake up or
in my dream it's like you feel that full
body tingling of immense horniness like
about to come
and then you wake up and then i always
remember those or the ones i do remember
become
my fantasies that is [ __ ] brilliant
it's so weird but like i try to manifest
in my dreams and i try to really like
see what my dreams are telling me and
your dreams are literally leading you to
orgasm yeah it's so crazy like i don't
know how why it started like that but it
has always been that way and the the
main one that i used for years
which is interesting was
i was going in for my first gynecology
visit and my doctor was a man this was
my dream it's not real interaction and
he was like all right we're just gonna
do your exam you know we're gonna test
put your body through some tests see if
it functions properly and basically
teaches me how to orgasm
and it's like don't worry like i know
i know what i'm doing just relax i'm
gonna make you orgasm and that for years
for years and years has made me just i
come so fast that's how they came up
with vibrators is depressed women were
going to doctors and they were with
hysteria oh really yeah they put
vibrators are you serious
i'm connected to like my past self
ancestral not trauma
[Applause]
sort of trauma i didn't have i don't
have that uh
joyous um um
links when
she was a doctor
by my
[Applause]
i need to do a reenactment and just you
know have a more positive outcome and
then maybe i can you know
start having um doctor kings i still
have this speculum from when we did the
gynecologist that is terrible i think i
don't know i don't know how you process
that like that would have to be
you'd have to if you're comfortable
reenacting it because the thing is like
thinking of a fantasy in your head where
it goes exactly how you imagine it to go
versus something happening in real life
you know is like so different well it
goes back to what i was saying earlier
where i truly think that my real life
has nothing to do with my sexual life
because i am able to reenact rape
fantasies and all these things that had
happened to me without too much of a
cost to my mental state that's how
because i s
the line between my real life and sex is
so clear that i think the doctor
reenactment wouldn't really bother me
honestly i think that could be a kink
that's amazing
but
i think tbd i think you should have that
i think you should have sex with carlos
dad
oh carla carlos was like so excited
until you said dad he's like
carlos
carlos um how what does your dad look
like
um better if he's an uggo yeah can we
see a picture of your dad yeah he's like
is he a doctor
can you please bring up your hot mexican
dessert wait uh is he still with your
mom
yeah oh yeah do they want a third
i feel like you'd be into it maybe
carlos can just put his dad's clothes on
and help you i'll wear scrubs okay yeah
yeah like a really nice doctor you have
to ball gag me in case i want to bite
you because i have trauma from doctors
it's called bald gagging when he does it
well when people when i tell people that
i have that fantasy they always think
it's doctor related but it's really not
like especially because my mom's an ob
gyn and she does my exams right
she's like related
like she's put in all my iuds oh yeah
um but i i really like i really don't
think they're related i think that it's
just a channel in my brain when i was
dreaming that
created an environment where someone's
like
don't worry about coming i'm just gonna
make you come oh you know when guys are
like oh can you come like come like
it it makes me not come but then when
someone's like i know what to do it also
makes sense to me because your mom was
always your guy now so it's like a
fantasy maybe to have a stranger do it
because you've never probably like
you've never been like oh my god still
into sucking your mouth that's so true
i've never had like someone i really not
familiar with go down there well that's
an every man i've ever been with i can't
even imagine being comfortable with the
person that's shoving a [ __ ] duck
bill in my opinion well i would be as
long as i don't see their faces so i'm
not good with like even when i watch um
porn i'm always looking at the woman i
never care about what trust me cut off
his head no one wants to see the man
like it is a rare person on the internet
that wants to see the man his face i
don't care about it so like my dream
business is a rub and tug for women
where we just don't see what he looks
like up top where is the glory hole yeah
it's just a glory hole but for women but
it's you know well monitored we have
professional men glorious
or just we just create men that have no
heads yeah
that's genetically you should hear that
a headless male population my dream come
true
i would be down for that yeah very much
so yeah
they don't even need to eat us out we
just don't care we're like we're down to
suck
i'll blow your neck
i'll blow your neck what is like
is there any content that you provide on
only fans that's like
most popular or like things that you're
surprised people are super into have you
learned anything weird about our general
population that way i mean
people
well one thing i've learned is like
there's someone into everything like
there you can find porn of literally
anything you have ever thought of
and there's going to be at least 100
people that are into it and probably
follow the subreddit for it
and i've gotten a mix of just
so many people on my only fans that are
into different stuff and it's opened my
eyes so much something i think i didn't
know before porn was like how many
people are into messy anal like people
want to see the anal where it's not
clean
and i mean like when i have sex with
guys in my personal life and it's not
filmed and it's messy they don't give a
[ __ ] yeah you know they're like oh
whatever i know i'm going in the
butthole yeah
and so i guess it makes sense that
there's guys who want to watch real anal
like that yeah i only had anal once with
this guy and it was like this agreement
we were going to have anal and he was
like older and really cool and i spent
all day like trying to clean my [ __ ]
out and make sure i wasn't going to show
i was like i'm just nervous i don't want
to shine her dick it's like if you [ __ ]
on
my dick i was involved and like we're
like equal partners
and like what usually happens or what
should happen is like you [ __ ] on their
dick and you never see it like they pull
out they go wash it you don't have to
face the fact you don't have to deal
with it we have joint custody over them
exactly exactly it's like yes you might
like be worried in the moment but you
don't have to see it they have to deal
with it they have to deal with their
consequences their actions and i bet you
they will want to go back in your
butthole they do not care guys will
literally clean off and then put it
right back in
do you have like double dip anal tips
like is there certain rules to follow to
be are you a popper girl do you like to
do a little no i've never done poppers
i'm actually like
i've mostly done anal sober i've never
done anal after drinking because i don't
really drink and i've done anal maybe a
couple times after smoking weed
which actually is amazing
but i do i like i [ __ ] every day sober
and i like it sober um but yeah i have a
lot of anal tips i have a ton do you
want them all yes like from start to
finish yes okay so first of all when i
lost my anal virginity i obviously did
not plan it like it was just a first
date
so i wasn't prepared so i had a first
date with where you're like he's going
rogue he's yeah i was on my period and
he was eating my ass and he just started
going in my butt i was like holy [ __ ]
that's my butt and then i was like oh my
god this is the most euphoric thing i've
ever felt in my life and i was the best
night ever the best sex probably ever
just because it was so new am i taking
it that you don't you don't have like a
hemorrhoid issue that's never been no
thing i think that might be like maybe a
genetic blessing of mine yeah yeah i'm
born to do this yeah i honestly like my
butthole is so stretchy and also i have
i have a high pain tolerance so i think
that's also and like i have a thing
where i like to be able to breathe
through painful challenging things and
get the euphoria on the other side of it
yeah so that's a big thing for me and i
think that's like if you want to try
anal that's like a big thing you should
probably prepare for but there also is i
didn't know for like the first year that
you can use lube that you can use
numbing lube or desensitizing lube which
like relaxes your muscles in your
butthole and you still feel just as much
if not more because you're not feeling
like that tight pain and you're actually
feeling the sensation and you're
probably surrendering more right because
that is like resistant yeah so i don't
use that anymore i've used it like a
couple times so i don't really need to
because i can relax my body enough but i
think that a lot of people could do anal
a lot easier if they use desensitizing
lube
so i study hypnotherapy and i'm like
maybe i should make a hypnosis for
people to get good at anal no for real
though because it's like porn
so
alex adams is this porn guy that i [ __ ]
for pornhub videos my two pornhub videos
are with him and he used to do gay porn
and now he does straight porn and so
he's like into gay stuff as well
straight stuff and he introduced me to
[ __ ]
hypno
uh compilations uh-huh so it's called
but it's [ __ ] hypno porn basically and
it's like to girls it's like normal porn
because it's the whole time it's been
like i want to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] i want to
be drenched in [ __ ] i want all your [ __ ]
but it's a niche kind of porn because
men watch it so it's like they're like
living out this trans [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
fantasy yeah and it's hypnotizing them
the whole time into being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and men watch it
i like that yeah it's amazing but it's
hypnosis porn and so if women watch it
like when i watched i was like oh my god
this is just me like this is just normal
and uh i have a question about um
when you do orgasm when you are getting
anal do you have to stimulate your front
simultaneously so
i have a really hard time having [ __ ]
orgasms or like [ __ ] orgasms when i'm
having anal because i'm so over
stimulated that i like i'll be vibrating
my [ __ ] and i won't feel anything like i
don't feel my [ __ ] at all and that's
also what anal does to me like after
anal i will feel euphoric like i don't
have one ache or pain in my whole body i
get very because it's such an intense
feeling that like afterwards i'm just
like floating on a cloud but you can't
orgasm just even just anal so the only
orgasms i mean sometimes i can have a
[ __ ] orgasm during anal but it's really
hard for me but i have ass orgasms which
i didn't know right thing but it
literally
it's really terrifying because it's kind
of like in the beginning you think
you're gonna [ __ ] it's like you know
that you know when you have like
explosive diarrhea and your whole body's
sweating and you're like your whole
body's tingling and you can't think and
you're having one right now everywhere
yeah
that's your feelings
so that feeling during anal if you lean
into it because i would say probably
usually it's not because you're [ __ ]
like i've never heard anything kind of
is for me too it's like leaning into
that resistance
yeah yeah and so when you lean into that
feeling it like gets more and more
intense and then it's exactly like an
orgasm where my whole body loses control
and like my butthole you know how when
you keep yourself yeah yeah my butthole
will like go like this and like because
and like lose control
i'm so immature i'm like laughing so
yeah
it's crazy i didn't know that existed
like like you know like after a big
sneeze it's kind of like orgasmic yeah
after a big [ __ ] is the same oh god yeah
yeah right or as you're shielding oh
and sometimes it's so painful you know
that you're like that you like start
hallucinating you know so it's not a
psychological orgasm it's a real
physical ass orgasm yeah i think because
it's like it's such a physical feeling
like my whole body basically loses
control right before that and i'm like
oh my god i almost feel like sometimes i
almost feel like i'm gonna throw up like
it feels it my whole body feels crazy
it's like and then it releases and it's
like oh my god do you like colonics
no okay is that when you
is that like suck the [ __ ] out of your
ass so true i have never done that
before
they shoot water up your ass and then
suck it up i guess i mean i've done like
douches where i shoot water up there and
then like push it out yeah to clean out
before anal which i never used to do but
then i started doing it recently it's
risky because water gets trapped up
there and then you have like poopy water
come out of you mid scene or mid sex
which is terrible yeah but there's 100
people that are into it there's a
hundred people that are into it there's
actually probably a good millionaire so
many people um
yeah in this in this county alone
there's a million or two
but
recently i've been filming with a lot of
girls and we've been doing anal content
together for the first time like i
normally only do anal with a guy and so
then we're doing like ass to mouth and
stuff and putting dildos in our butts in
their mouths and i want like it's nice
if my butthole's actually clean yeah
like i wash out like every even if it's
clean you want to make sure there's not
like certain bacteria
yeah exactly
exactly
maybe that's why you feel like you're
about to throw up
hardcore i mean that's that's been
something that i always worry about when
i've eaten a guy's house
it's just like okay some of the guys i
feel like girls exactly because like the
girls like i feel like really tend to
our lady bits really well i don't know
i've got guys are a little bit less
conscious about it yeah also balls i
feel like are like extra
but thankfully thankfully every [ __ ]
i've eaten has been like pristine
conditions thankfully and i always feel
like really respected in that moment
i've honestly yeah i've never gotten
strep from eating ass
which is that it's a risk it's a risk
and actually i realize now so i got
strapped like five times in a row in the
last two years
and i
in two years five times yeah it was
really bad and so i thought that it was
from ask to mouth like when
because there were a few times like a
girl would pull out a shitty butt plug
and i put it in my mouth right right and
so but what i actually after going to a
lot of doctors about this what i figured
out is one
every like probably 50 of people give or
take carry
strep group b in their vaginas on their
skin
just anywhere harmlessly it's not like
an std or anything it's just there you
don't notice it and i'm hypersensitive
to it and the first time i got
introduced to strep groupie was when i
worked with this other girl
and i put her shitty butt plug in my
mouth and she had it you know in her
colon which is where it is in most
people how did you know did you
well i because i got strep i got i got
really sick like a fever like super
super sick and they they tested me for
strep normal strep which is group a and
i didn't have it and they did way more
tests found out it was strep group b
which is like oh you've been in contact
with the intestinal drag
i was like yeah i do you pass a lot and
so then i thought
that's what it was from but then i
started getting it just randomly where
and then the
the last time i didn't do anything
related to a butthole i just worked with
a new girl and a new guy at the same
time and i got strep after and so then
that's when i started going to a doctor
like why am i getting recurrent strep
and it's because my i probably have to
get my tonsils out if it happens again
but basically my body is just
hypersensitive to that so even if i like
am with a new person and kiss them and
they carry strep group b just on their
skin or a girl in their vagina like i
will get a strep infection from it
so which is not yeah most people don't
get that and like they haven't ever
dealt with that before but for some
reason i'm just like hyper sensitive to
it that's right but yeah i did think it
was always from like eating ass or
mouth but it's really it could be just
as well from a vagina or or anything so
i had to have drew take antibiotics
because i think i was like getting it
from him just being on his skin yeah he
got it from me
and now i haven't had it in a while now
okay you're
successful
you're horny you're young
we've talked a lot about sex
you you clearly you you kind of have
made it financially on your own what do
you do in your like what do you do for
fun like that's not sex because now sex
is you know connected to work sometimes
yeah
i don't know like what's your fun times
i read a lot
i love to read i run well i broke my toe
last month so i haven't been running
esther
my toe right the day before i flew to
japan so i had to go to japan in a
wheelchair it was a big moment you and
me
broken toes suck yeah i haven't been
able to run in a minute
and i'm like i'm going a little bit
insane
but i should be able to run like
starting next week again good esther why
don't you give us some tips about broken
toes yeah well it sounds like you're
through the hardest part i i don't know
if i have tips but i will just
it's it's so much harder than you think
you really you don't think you need that
people are like stop being a [ __ ] no
you can walk and i literally couldn't i
think it sent me into like one of my
bigger depressions yes yeah i think it's
why i had to go on lex pro because hey
we're both on likes of road too yeah we
have way too many similarities which toe
oh my god so it's this one right here
that wasn't what i broke really
okay so this like
it's it still looks a little wonky
because when i looked down at it after
stubbing it my nail like my
it had flipped like this so my nail was
facing sideways oh no and it's still a
little bit
sideways
because i broke it and dislocated it at
the same time so they pop it back into
place which was terrible and then they
had to like align it this esther's wiki
feet yep oh god
wow your little toe oh my god that's
what mine looked like it was so bruised
it was like the scariest how did you
break yours
so funny you asked i
had just heard that a new episode of
2020 was coming out that i was really
excited to watch so i ran in the other
room to get my glasses and i was too
thrilled that i smashed my foot into a
foam roller at a high speed foam roller
broke it yeah
wow yeah i know i look frail and fragile
and it's i am yeah that's what i thought
when i when i stubbed mine i was like
i've stuffed my toes so many times in my
life and i stop at this one time and it
dislocates and breaks when i stubbed it
in the same spot like last week and
nothing happened yeah you feel so i was
like are my bones getting frail like do
i need to take supplements yeah weird
angle you get it at that one moment oh
and that's how i knew it was different
because at first it just was searing
pain like all stubbed toes are but then
i started going into shock which i've
been in before when i broke both my
wrists at the same time so i knew what
it was and it's like your vision goes
black and white and black and white yeah
and i was like
and your broken wrist like
yeah exactly i was 13.
rollerblading um mountain biking
mountain biking oh hardcore so outside
of
you know like esther said
only fans being this like successful
star like what do you ever like tap into
what you think is like you know your
wholesome self like completely separate
from that i honestly feel like i'm such
a wholesome person and i said the work
that i do
is my sex life like my porn that i put
on only fans and my nudes and stuff are
just my regular sex life and what i'm
already doing and would be doing so
first it like doesn't feel like work at
all and it's just me getting to live my
life and [ __ ] the people i want to [ __ ]
and
like you know drew will just take photos
of me when i wake up and i'm naked and
that will just go straight on only fans
or we'll [ __ ] in the morning and just
put it up on only fans and then i just
go about my day like i read a lot i
always go on runs every day
i
love interior designs i'm like always
furniture shopping
i want to buy property really bad so
i've been looking at that i'm about to
help my mom buy a house
oh
yeah
i love my mommy
um
i i think i'm like i'm a very like fun
goofy wholesome person even in all my
porn the nice thing is i actually get to
live a full life outside of work which
is why i went into porn in the first
place because so many people like their
lives become their work whether it's you
know you're a doctor and you're working
for yourself but you're still like
having to focus on patients all day long
every day and then you get two hours in
the evening before you go to sleep to be
yourself and then you get
two days on the weekend to be yourself
and then you're back focusing on work or
whether you're like a person that's
working a grocery store or something and
you're getting just paid to take chunks
of your life
out for a company and you get to live
your real self in your real life an hour
a day or something right and i get to
live
my
life how i want to
all day long every day and maybe i work
for an hour to a day
on like posting my content
and then other than that i just get to
just bounce around travel and play and
what would you say is the biggest
drawback of sharing so much of who you
are
i would say it's nearly impossible to
not
question yourself like i've been always
very confident but when you start
putting your real vulnerable self on the
internet which i think is necessary to
really gain a community yeah at the same
time there's just going to be so much
hate
and it as much as like it didn't affect
me in the beginning because i was
putting a certain part of my personality
out there so it felt kind of like a
character like it was just my super
horned up side
as i've had to evolve on the internet
i've had to share more of my and wanted
to share more of myself and what i
actually believe and talk about like it
was a big deal to even say talk about i
went to college like a year and a half
into making content online i told people
i went to school which is something i
value so much about myself and is so
sacred and i was so scared to put out
there because i was like people want to
ruin everything for you and so then of
course the moment i put out is
everyone's like oh i don't believe you
like show your degree blah blah and it's
like i'll never do that because they
just try and ruin everything that's
special to you
and so
i've had to learn to you know not read
comments and like get over that but it's
a lot easier in the beginning i think
and then as it goes on with time and and
your job and your content becomes so
personal to you and you're sharing such
personal stuff it's really hard to to
see so much criticism and hate all the
time and like that's definitely it's
that's definitely i think we could
probably all over yeah
that's universal
and it's like this is my punishment like
for going into this amazing job and
doing all this like the one thing is
like i have to be perceived by people
and you can't control how you're
perceived by yeah maybe that is the
healthy way to look at it too i always
try to think of it as this there is this
balance like we get to do this like
amazing thing you know and be ourselves
and other stuff so maybe that the
counterbalance is that there's just
going to be this and in the beginning i
looked at it smarter i looked at it more
like a business person whereas now it's
like i share these things and i just get
my feelings hurt but in the beginning i
was like the more hate i get on videos
like this is a scientific fact the more
hate i get on the videos the more they
blow up and the more money i make so if
i you know troll the internet and i hate
farm i make way more money and so in the
beginning when i was playing this like
horny character i was just saying crazy
[ __ ] because i was like this is the one
way i can get a lot of attention and
make a lot of money and so it was
positive to get that hate and i didn't
take it personal and then i started
shifting and getting girl fans and like
saying how i actually felt about stuff
and sharing my other parts of my
personality and then when people hate on
it it's like [ __ ] i totally relate this
is like my only thing i have dude i know
because on tick-tock i'm just like
putting myself out there my ideas my
thoughts and then when a whole group of
people like hates it you're just it it
does it's something that i'm constantly
working on of like
how to get that not too much i think
it's like so
for me it was like [ __ ] when i realized
that i was like this is
such an and i'm a strong person like i'm
a really strong person and this is such
an unnatural thing for humans to have to
do is to deal with thousands of
perspectives on you every single day
that's why and i was like maybe i
shouldn't [ __ ] do this not natural
but who else will right someone else and
then i'm like all right you know my job
is so good it's like we just have to be
like look at it as like love it's like
people sending you love in their own way
and like it's the same as like with the
incels what you were saying before with
guys where it's like you know
it's all like their [ __ ] and uh we
totally can like get past it and rise
above it but it is so [ __ ] weird like
i posted
um
like just a clip of me telling like the
story of when i lost my virginity and
someone's like this is so cringe like
the story from my life yes
like how could just an experience in my
life be crazy exactly and the thing is
too it's it it feels like something i
have to deal with because i'm making
content but it's actually something that
every single person in the world deals
with because there's always people that
aren't going to be happy with you you
might go to school to do something that
your parents think is good like the
right career but there's going to be a
ton of other people that hate that job
even my mom her next-door neighbor hates
doctors yeah so my mom tells her she's a
doctor she's like oh my god you're part
of the complex like you're the
world i'm like even if you're a doctor
even if you're the president of the
united states you have a lot of haters
like no matter what you do in life no
not everyone love you there will be a
subreddit once again that hates on you
yeah except
my dream job is to be a fedex delivery
guy but hear me out
it's a fedex delivery guy on a rural
route
with every household having a dog i can
say hi to i found this guy on tick-tock
that's basically what he does
he records the dogs he says hi so he
drops off um the packages everyone says
hi to him everyone loves him all the
dogs are friendly i'm like this is what
i do but he's only posting the ones of
the dogs that like but also there's
probably there's dogs that hate him
listen you want to aim for some
i heard like you want to aim for like 51
percent like you're successful at 51 no
i bet you how there's so many men too on
the internet they're like pathetic that
guy's living a pathetic what a loser
yeah oh yeah like just right you're
right you're right
but cowardly
trash my dreams guys
it doesn't explain her outfit today
though
dress for the job that you want honestly
it sounds like a beautiful job and it
sounds even more beautiful if he didn't
have tik tok and he just did it
those are the people that live the
nicest lives since when they live in
their little bubble where they don't
have haters they don't know they have
haters they do but if you think about
the people that are like i mean i don't
know who is but if you're like loved by
everyone you suck probably that's the
thing is like if you're loved by
everybody you're not pushing hard enough
and you're probably not gonna get like a
really big profitable career because
like the [ __ ] that blows up and this was
before the internet too but it's
especially true on the internet
has hate like hate is way more powerful
than love yeah so [ __ ] goes viral
because so many people hate comment
people don't love comment nearly as much
as they hate comment
and and your people will love you more
if they see people hating on you yeah
every time someone hates on me there's
so many girls in the comments like
i love it it creates some real ones i
know it's so interesting when you get
the girl when you're like this you could
get girl followers and this is what i do
oh my god like you guys are so nice i
love her it happens girls on the
internet are wonderful i know i have
never been more bullied on the internet
than when i started getting girl fans oh
really like men will just be like l
[ __ ] fatherless you know but secretly
they're like hot you know yeah women are
like they will tear apart every part of
your being they will either support you
is it the christian thought of women it
will be anyone interest women it will be
anyone like literally any type of girl
like will just
if they don't agree with you or they're
threatened by especially i think
honestly i think porn girls experience
this a lot because i think a lot of
women are intimidated by girls that do
porn and feel like you know they taking
their husbands yeah they're insecure
about their own sexuality or something
and we they feel like we're you know
stealing yeah they're their prospects
and so like women can literally tear
every single part about my appearance
and my voice and everything definitely
hey oh that makes me so easy but men
won't create subreddits hating on you
men will just be like be surprised
so it's weird for all of us it's
literally the opposite so that's what it
says is everyone's a hater yeah it's
it's the opposite for us like our girl
gang is so strong i have a strong girl
gang but i also a lot of haters i also
never have people come up and say mean
things to me ever and oh no yes i never
ever ever oh it's all online yeah yeah
so i feel like maybe we just need to
radical acceptance yeah at all yeah of
course we have to and also it's just
like it is the price we pay and like we
if everyone else is getting it why
wouldn't we and what i tell girls going
into porn i'm like one you need the
haters to blow you up but two you don't
need a lot of fans to live a nice life
and to make good money and have a good
career like you don't need to win over
the entire world that's literally insane
and it's not possible you just need to
foster a small community of people who
love and support you and that's it and
if that's your focus
then being getting approval from
everyone really doesn't matter yeah i've
been watching so many documentaries of
like
like i watched the shania twain
documentary
oh my god they're all so good but
they're all it's all the same thing it's
all like
that i saw the taylor swift one where
the shania twain one really broke my
heart because i didn't know this about
her but she lost her voice from lyme
disease she was doing big arenas and
what i love about shania twain is she
didn't make it in her 20s she was a
30-something woman who was absolutely
destroying like her trajectory was a
little bit slower to start i love women
like that and it's like
all of a sudden she had one big like
arena show and then she was like
something's happening like i can't sing
anymore and then she later got diagnosed
with lyme disease and it was right when
her husband had just cheated on her with
her best friend best friend slash
assistant and then she ended up she
ended up marrying her ex best friend's
husband oh my god but she didn't really
talk about it on the did she talk about
on the documentary no but he was way
hotter than the original was so hot but
you know what i mean but what i related
to was so her husband was this guy i
can't remember what his last name is
muddling yeah mutt lang so he was like
this huge music producer and he really
helped her take her career to like the
next level and really like launched it
big big and so she felt so afraid when
they broke up to like go back into the
studio without him and she had to like
find her own voice again and i feel like
um i relate to that when i dated comics
where kind of like they almost like they
were
more successful than me or older than me
in the business and they kind of like
i felt like i had to break up like i had
to
break my ties with them to kind of find
my own voice and everything so i really
like related to that too
that's so beautiful it was so cute i'm
gonna watch it i know you wanna watch it
really inspiring she's so pretty i just
love her and the other one you had you
guys have to watch is tina turner's
documentary i haven't watched your video
so freaking good because not only was
she a black woman in her 50s but she
didn't she wanted to sing rock and roll
she was a freaking rock star so she her
career didn't she didn't make it in
america first she made it in the uk
first because the uk was very accepting
of this you know of just rock and roll
in general they didn't care if she was
like a middle-aged black woman what a
badass dude [ __ ]
the the most badass ever
um
i think this has been my favorite
episode yeah this was so good thank you
so much i flew by i know wait i have one
more question that i wanted to ask from
the previous episode we talked about but
you talked about having a purple kitty
i'm so glad you're bringing this up
because i was like purple [ __ ] eater i
kept going purple
you talk about being a being a purple
kitty having a purple kitty and um the
genetics behind that the haplogenes can
you explain yeah so my mom taught me
this and i don't know how she like the
doctors have a lot of knowledge that i
don't know where she gets it from but
she did a
23 me test
like three years ago
and figured out that we have the h1 gene
which is in the h haplogroup and the h1
gene is it but there's like certain
genes that show
where your ancestors migrated
throughout evolution right so the the
working theory now is that like humans
started in africa right like as a small
small community and then we slowly
spread out throughout the world
and the h1 gene is traced back to to the
group of people that as they were
migrating out of africa migrated through
lebanon and syria and then up into
europe
and is that why they call it
labias
yeah only them developed labia
only those women
but um
so it doesn't mean like it's so far in
the past obviously we're all traced back
to to that that it's not like i'm
lebanese or anything which some people
like think when i say this but it's that
that's where my ancestors migrated
through when humans were first migrating
from africa
and
that is associated with having darker
genitalia it's not like a hundred
percent of the time but it's associated
with having more melanin
and darker
um
areas on your
your [ __ ] on your darker lips darker
nipples darker [ __ ] maybe yeah darker
[ __ ] my [ __ ] is the same color as
my [ __ ] and i want to show you guys my
[ __ ] so bad
i'll show you later
it's kind of like it's a multi-colored
some parts are um um it's tie-dye it
isn't
um some parts are a little pinker some
parts are very like a neutral brown and
some parts are a little bit darker so
maybe those are the h1 parts and like
i'd never called my [ __ ] a purple [ __ ]
and my mom didn't call it purple either
we just have the same darker [ __ ] but
then when i was
uh when i first got with drew he was
like oh my god you have a purple [ __ ]
and that's like a thing a lot of guys
say which i didn't know but it's like
when he had
latina girlfriends in the past he was
like they also had purple [ __ ] and
that's like a lot of latinas and a lot
of spanish heritage too have um the h1
gene
and then of course there's like there's
like other groups of people you know
that migrated out of africa through
siberia and they have completely
different genetic traits and like
completely different shapes of vaginas
and uh
different colored vaginas you know a lot
pinker like there's a lot of women that
just have fully pink vaginas and then
i'm just a white woman that has a really
really dark butthole and now i kind of
know why and why and why every woman in
my family has the same one too yeah
so you guys ever line them up and just
wear them well the craziest thing is my
mom and i have because she's always
naked around yeah
we talked about this i love episodes
but we literally have
we have the same nipples the same lips
and the exact same [ __ ] and [ __ ] lips
like the exact same like my mom's look
the exact same because she like was her
mom's daughter wait do you have darker
nipples too yeah okay so i don't i have
really light pink nipples but my [ __ ]
is so you're really a mixture yeah
you're a mixture of a lot yeah
are mine darker let me see let me see
light very light faster
i mean actually bars are really similar
colored right now
see mine
but yeah but when i get horny which is a
thing or when i'm on my period or like
you know if you get pregnant
you're melanin aren't they light is this
light yeah this is yeah pink it's like
it's actually like the color of mine but
it's when you um
get hornier and when you're on your
period or your hormones peak they get
darker also when you're pregnant yeah
exact same thing oh [ __ ] just one more
thing guys i swear to god because i i i
need to get your mom is a is uh ob gyn
but um i heard of this thing called a
phantom pregnancy that i always knew
dogs had when they weren't about those
dogs so dogs i i've always known about
the dogs that when they don't get spayed
they go into this like fake pregnancy
they get all the hormones they start
looking for babies they'll never have
they start like crying
it turns out that women can get phantom
pregnancies you guys that's crazy and
it's not just a psychological thing
where it's not like oh i think i'm
pregnant and then you think they're just
crazy no like their their cervix gets
softer their uterus gets bigger hormones
their hormones are doing everything like
a pregnant person except when you do an
ultrasound there's no baby oh you know i
do feel like my mom has been mentioned
this to me before i really do i'm not
asking about it so it's a cycle it
starts off psychological and it's women
who sometimes have had multiple
miscarriages
um um there's a lot of different reasons
but it starts off as a psychological
thing but then you almost trick your
body into fully having
all of the pregnancy um
no you don't test positive on the test
the babies the phantom babies they're
like our bodies are so incredible
put on your back
and our thoughts and everything can
affect it so much everything i'm telling
you that part those people hypnotize
their bodies into being pregnant it's
like the law of attraction right like
you can look at a single atom and you
can recreate this in the lab and you can
almost will it to operate a certain way
you know
without even touching it or manipulating
it in any way and our brains do control
our whole body you know they control
everything every hormone that's released
everything so it's not like we fully
even understand and even like you know
when they say like men have sympathy
pregnancies and that's people just think
that that's like a myth that's a real
physiological phenomenon that happens
imagining todd like
lactating
this is like mildly unrelated but sort
of it's like the opposite my mom always
told me growing up like to go into the
doctor when i thought something was
wrong
because she would always use the story
of how many women would come in with a
belly this big like a full pregnant
belly
and they had had it for like two three
years and they thought they were
pregnant the whole time and it was
really just a tumor that was growing and
since it was growing they literally just
thought that they were pregnant and they
just kept it there and they never saw a
doctor and they just assumed they were
pregnant for three years what are they
elephants well then it's like a mental
illness right but it's like she's always
like just go get checked out because
there are women that just assume they're
pregnant when really it's a massive
tumor that's destroying our body that
could have been just cut out like
in the beginning that'd be kind of fun
to you know get it pause play pregnant
cosplay pregnant and you know get all
the pregnancy perks because people do
treat you a little bit nicer definitely
the parking perks the parking perks
i feel like this is something esther
which i know i'm like
like how do i manifest the tumor
has like a like a placard that says
pregnant
you could do that even if you don't have
pregnant belly right but then people
probably don't believe you you have to
drag your right hand a little bit
you have to like waddle a little you
have to yeah you have to like
i think you can settle for a fake
pregnant belly instead of a tumor yeah
thank you yeah thank you i won't judge
you get that back girl you
you get that parking space well i'm
about to piss my pants so
thank you so much
for being here and joining us i've been
with excitement the whole time and also
to come back i would love to i will come
back with updates about the phantom
pregnancy yeah let me know and other fun
and i will keep you updated on what was
it earlier um my um dr king yes your
second like
reenactment see how that goes i honestly
want to know where does your mom live
she lives in orange county maybe we
should have you and your mom on you know
she has been recently like because she's
so proud of me now
and she like her employees also
they know who i am and they know i'm her
daughter and then their friends will be
like telling them oh my god i love
stella on tick tock and the the her
employee like won't tell them oh my my
employer is like her mom because we keep
it confident yeah
but recently she's been like because i
sent all my porn friends to her even
sawyer has been to her yeah i will see
her recently she's been willing to take
us on yeah recently yeah she's literally
so amazing i'll give you guys her car
but she um she's been recently like hey
i would happily educate alongside you
like i would happily like be associated
that's kind of amazing i would love it
i love my mom yeah but also she's a
freaking genius like she's a genius and
she she because she's
able to communicate things so simply
about your health well it's like don't
they i mean jada and willow do it on red
table talk you should have your own
version of that mother dog exactly i
honestly think that would be so smart
but it's also you're like breaking the
stigma of like that it's like unhealthy
to do porn or that family or you have to
come from some like horrible background
but i learned that stigma was all
[ __ ] very early on because one of my
good friends is asa akira
and from the moment that i met her i
found her to just be absolutely [ __ ]
brilliant and she comes from a really
good family a lot of people are like
that important because it's just and a
lot of them are brilliant because it
takes a lot to
do something society doesn't look well
right one it takes a lot of courage to
do that i have to say i learned a lot
about business from my friendship with
brie olsen
she is a smart [ __ ] yeah are all our
mentors porn stars yes
moving forward especially yeah yeah porn
girls
they are like
they're ballsy
what and they make their own businesses
tell your mom she is open there's an
open invitation that would be really
cool
yeah if she's ready to face the world
we're we're ready for her um we will be
showing her she i'm gonna show her this
she's gonna love it so much i'll
immediately be
spread leg yeah
can you tell me do i look normal
well part of me is h1 again yeah
when we had dr drew on we were like
like when we get a doctor and we go nuts
yeah my mom is the best you guys thank
you so much for listening and definitely
check out stella's work i know i will be
doing that um with my nerves
you're pretending
i will be checking it out
um and we'll see you guys next week
thank you stella thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]
you